we're live welcome to the iron Lord
podcast episode number 17 and this is
part of the e3 2017 prediction series
part two and we've got some special
guests in the building and this is a
guest a lord that actually I've been
watching for some time he puts out great
content and um really like his views on
a lot of things in gaming member of
switch gang so also appropriate that
he's on ship as well and um this is the
producer and the host of the for game
for guys with quarters podcast and also
a panelist for the TX our podcast one of
the premiere xbox podcast out I would
like to introduce my man Lord infernal
is in the building how are you doing sir
kognito what's going on gentlemen
thank you for making me an honorary Lord
today I'm excited to talk about the
switch and some destiny - and if we get
to that little which a thing that
happened on Netflix oh it's about to
happen we get to it but if we don't I'm
not too sad so let's just do it put the
gun away
no it's no it was a slow news week yeah
and by the way also got a shuttle Lord
infernal has one of the best Twitter
avatars out there I love your Twitter I
was always meeting the shouts on it
where did you get that dunce
man you know graphic God Jay Jay dubs
you know Jay Williams he gets it done I
mean support him on face he approached
me he said what do you want done I told
him he got it on the first try I said
you know shout-out to you man I gotta
always show nice not advertise nice
definitely the most fire avatar on
Twitter loved it
daddy sir and of course we have family
back in the building my man the
nightfall soloist the the newly ready to
talk destiny - he's been chomping at the
bit - so we have a
why me Loic boxes how we doing sir we
are doing good heads about to explode
with everything to take him this week
but it's been it's been an interesting
week so far and yeah looking forward to
pretty much all to discuss I don't want
to jump in too much but I always
appreciate you guys uh you know
knighting me in the weeks I do get to
show up for the the Lord title so
deserving enough but I appreciate the
the invite every time so thank you guys
absolutely anytime guys Lords in your
realm and on this round as well and of
course we have the usual suspects at the
roundtable co-hosts with the co-host my
man that non aggregator himself Lord
addict is in the building how we doing
sir what's up you guys there been just
chillin man you know but a slow week for
games besides you know destiny but you
know I feel like destiny to his
announcement was enough because it's got
the whole internet up and running it and
it has been broken
yes yes that's good there and of course
we have the lamented tech general no
longer Illuminati my name Lord sovereign
how we doing sir doing very well sir
doing very very well man just uh he's
going nuts on the switch man like
honestly every single week I feel is a
broken record new this new that but
they're disfavor thumper man that
thumper has new one we looked up real
tall dick Tibet we go get to the
absolutely we definitely got a lot to
say about that so that's good that
you're out there in that shop I see
that's good nice and of course I'm an
the XS gamer the Lord is nothing more
than the less the premium experience my
man beloved of Lord King how we doing
sir
they do are fantastic and uh to count at
that point it's been a great week of
video games if you happen to have
everything so in the winter yes
to which we will get that thank you we
got a lot of topics Muji
run put real brief before we start um
just want to get an idea of what the
Lord's are playing so uh Lord infernal
what have you been playing this week
what's been on your your gaming systems
man I mean I've got I got PC ps4 switch
Xbox of course you know how it is
um so I'll give you the new title I'll
be giving a little bit of everything
I've been checking out that quake
champions beta that thing is on man if
you were you were into quake back in the
day you will absolutely love quake
champions coming off a PC I don't think
it's coming to console but I'm sure
we'll get some more details at
Bethesda's III conference on that um for
PlayStation been playing horizon zero
dawn been playing NBA playground on
PlayStation oh yeah I haven't seen a lot
of people rage at that game
yeah that game is is frustrating to say
the least and the rebounding extremely
suspect yeah I know what you mean mm-hm
on Xbox been playing some battlefield 1
been playing some Flint hook been
playing some Forza horizon DLC of course
Oh Hot Wheels that Hot Wheels did so so
good and on switch been playing a little
boy boy Oh Tetris playing some wonder
boy I got that on the switch I feel like
it plays perfectly on the switch I
decided to get it on that I'm playing
some blaster master and of course Kart 8
which I think even though Zelda's on
there I think my riccati is the best
thing on that console most accessible
you may have some points David level oh
it is so much fun it's up there it's up
there he'll be some good choices well
like what you playing Lord infernal yeah
a lot of good things going lordy Lordy
Burns's what have you been playing this
week I was I said it I saw invade
playgrounds was 20 bucks so I did decide
to pick that one up just to see and yeah
as you were saying that whole rebound
thing man that's history what there's
some jenkki Nazaire and a couple things
but still kind of fun to just kind of
get a little pickup game as opposed to
just something quite so simulation to us
I saw someone almost break his
controller over the game
I'm not surprised but I mean it's been
pretty fun of course little bestie
they're honest I've just been playing
the media players on my computer looking
at videos over and over kind of breaking
everything down rim by frame in between
work so I've been playing a whole lot of
play buttons on videos and stuff like
that but of course a little horizon a
little bit of that in there of course
man I want to get back into that game
seven at a time yeah it's the nest egg
destiny twos have to be pretty sucked up
this week so yeah I'll save my breath
till we get to talk about that one
absolutely sir absolutely
and what addict what have we been
playing sir well I've been playing
consoles that's for sure cuz my xbox
Xbox still down what's what's the ETA or
the one return what's what's going on
with that they just received it today
Jesus you should get it back before t3
mob I highly doubt I will but uh yeah
what since I lost my xbox you know I was
playing Darksiders but I kind of had to
take a step back on that it would sucks
is by the time I get my console back I
might not even have the drive the flight
Darksiders anymore
my cousin stores got me back into
runescape somehow somehow okay so I've
been playing out cool cool any switch
touching oh we kind of I play the Mario
Kart for a little bit yesterday but I
played so much of it on the the the way
you know I just can't keep myself on it
for a longer than 30 or 40 minutes I got
you got you that's cool and dumb Lord
seven what have you been playing um let
me see I've been so like I said before a
lot of a lot of switch man that thumper
that's thumper has me going man like
it's soft
is it freaky is it it's Rick it's like
it's like a horror rhythm game and it's
just like it gets
tenser and tenser as it goes along and
it doesn't really tell you a lot about
how you how to navigate it so it's a lot
of trial and error and it just went
again when you get in that zone you get
in that zone and emotions start being
perfectly in tune with the with the
music I mean that's it's like this this
feeling that you can't really you can't
really describe like your
snow and then like it's a beautiful and
it runs beautifully on the switch um I
feel my lords on the on the MBA
playgrounds I've been playing and like
when it comes to the tournaments as you
get higher and higher in the tournaments
yeah they get cheaper and cheaper so
it's a grind is definitely a grind um
let me see
and then I'm PS Pro I played a little
bit of horizon try and get back to that
and then yesterday as a severely laughs
to latch the destiny player I got on the
Xbox and tried to play a little destiny
did that see you why did I get the memo
coming out of the Illuminati playing a
multiplayer social game I was playing by
myself oh you ain't gonna be playing it
very long coming back vanilla destiny
right now you know I can jump in and I
can you know I can get to level 40 and I
can play certain things by myself cuz
you guys already played all that stuff
so you know it's not that bad no doubt
though though in Lord King what have we
been playing this week I've been
touching a little bit of everything I
sent my mini to go get a hacked and you
know jailbroken to put the 600 games on
um you to my video the only strategy
investment yes yes I see you guys
playing thumper I'm gonna do a little
still little wait see because I wasn't
gonna put up the playgrounds not so good
but um my pro has been in a lot of love
this week oh gee with the zero rising
dawn okay uh I went in I didn't want to
go in with the bias uh you know playing
Zelda so much and when you get to the
dawn you're like oh I can't climb every
wall okay you can't climb as your wall
in every game anyway oh is it truly open
world you know so stupid little
questions that you have I started
appreciating the game for what the game
was the 4k resolution it was very
beautifully done uh you know the
artistic views of the game is fantastic
control is fantastic so I'm really
trying
immerse myself in the game um and then
Oh though though the four point I can't
say this enough this is their killer app
and I really wish they would push it a
little bit further but I don't think
they push the VR because they don't have
the unit's to put out I really don't
think so a shame I paid a good things I
also see a shout out the Lord boring I
see him up here all promoting it heavy
and rocking and I'm hearing great things
about it so love you oh also um please
uh everybody uh pick up battle islands
so free-to-play game on the Xbox see you
won't had a lot I play I play it
religiously okay it's a religious a
little drug that I have I think it's
safe to say he might play that more than
he plays anything else but every time
yeah I'm usually not that's all I see
you like a lot of times when I look at
my friend list that's what you're
rocking yeah it is the most addictive
little game going is the fact that you
can go and attack somebody's Idol and
when they're not looking
still all a money just do something evil
today Island stealing money like you can
go in you can send one guy and just to
just do something terrible to just mess
with somebody and they come back and
it's like uh like you have camouflage it
is the most immersive free-to-play
sneaky
take all your money destroy your Island
[ __ ] up your dig game I gotta check it
out free to fly you got me you want here
so me at that left right now like it
doesn't cost you a thing baby jump aside
and grouted goodness look look I need
over here for me it's been all kind of
similar with the rest of the laws been
playing I touched I downloaded dumper my
thoughts exactly what more sovereign
that thing is just trippy I mean that
thing has you clenching the switch tight
but it's just so well done like I love
everything about it
I wouldn't even like I heard it was a
psvr game right locating so yeah sure so
I can't even imagine being isolated with
a VR headset without imported it cuz
that game had me tripping in my house
which is headphones by itself but on
on the VR that's probably I would I
played it probably three or four times
that you know packs are you three or
whatever yeah I would say they're on the
psvr it's definitely top five experience
on there and now the thumper game
actually was up for Game of the Year
awards at the video game awards for its
PR presence yeah yeah that's what it was
like I said I'm bummed and it definitely
had a big discussion about that being
game of the year they they loved it so
much on VR mm-hmm yeah it's definitely
meant for it like I can it I can't even
like this is wow it's just such a trippy
experience and I just want to know what
the developers were thinking when it
just kidding but other than that I touch
phantom dust actually did the other yeah
yeah I mean is free so you know yeah
that's true I love Phil but you know I
don't know what the big infatuation with
it were they did I did touch it I'll bet
the game for what it is but like it it's
nothing to brag about like by any means
this I really weren't a YouTube video
shut up a lot of fur no because I was
watching a flag as recorders and I think
you guys nailed it with that your
assessment of it man you know like that
game was so bad that I forgot when you
just asked me I was playing I got even
played it like I'm trying to erase my
memory man like that [ __ ] because
honestly terrible exist a nothing for
the Xbox community BB to be bragging
about as an exclusive yeah
mark I think the big question would have
something to say about that big fan I
think the big issue with that game isn't
even necessarily that you know it is it
exists it's the fact that they started
out with a remake and they then they cut
it down to like you know re-release and
it's the fact that we the last time we
got an exclusive with saber Wars - yeah
totally I totally feel you with the
Lords of saying on that so yes I mean it
is what it is I mean if there is some
foundation there but you know I don't
know if it's gonna be enough to generate
interest for a sequel but that's been
pretty much it for me this week but
we're gonna jump right into it we got a
big show going on so obviously this is
part 2 of the e3 2017 prediction series
and Nintendo is up to bat
so it was fitting that we had our man
Lord inferno in because he's a switch
gang and a lot of us all actually
everyone here the round table is a
switch gang but um wanted to start off
with this week I want to start off with
um if anyone first caught any of the
Nintendo Direct then also I want to jump
right into III predictions what do you
know what do we think Nintendo is going
to do we obviously they have a lot of
tremendous momentum right now the sales
NPD I mean this train is rolling so I
want to start off with Lord infernal our
guests and what do you think about
Nintendo at e3 your predictions and also
did you get a chance to UM watch the
direct this week I believe with arms in
arms platoon - I caught some of the arm
stuff the arm stuff I got to be honest
you have to see in the direct I'm a
little bit more down on arms than I was
before because the arms is the game that
is one of the only games I've ever seen
- zero hype for it and then the more
they keep showing the more people like
you know what I could get down on this
game a little bit better for good yeah I
mean it trust me I said when I started
pax this year you know even before pax
at the at the initial reveal before the
release of the thing I thought it was
going to be exceptional I thought and if
they kept I thought they kept you know a
few things under wraps about you know
game modes maybe a story mode that was
more substantial I thought maybe that it
would be a full fledged $60 experience
the more I see it though that you know
that's the only part of the direct that
I caught I would say that I'm a little
hesitant now 460 but fully hopefully
they released some more stuff to to get
me a little more excited on it but about
the about uh about e3 what I expect
I think the showstopper moment I think a
lot of people here would agree probably
would be another Metroid game and I
don't know let's go I bought this is
smiling right now yeah
but they so we want and you know like
the more I think about it the more I
think I could see something like a
Metroid game that you switch between
side-scrolling in first-person I think
that would be really cool obviously I
have no inside knowledge whatsoever but
I keep thinking you know some some games
been able to do that successfully we
switch between you know the Third's in
the first-person mode I can just imagine
playing like Super Metroid and ultra
high graphics ultra high 60 frames per
second fidelity and there'd be sections
where you know you could switch in
first-person mode maybe they can throw
some motion controls in there and then
switch right back to the third-person to
the side-scrolling that we all loved we
were kids and you know capture that
audience again I think Metro would be
the show-stopping moment um but yeah
other than that I think they'll probably
show another donkey kong country kind of
game i think they'll talk more in depth
about the online service maybe they've
had second thoughts about charging for
phone app i mean not
maybe we'll get a price that is extreme
is noble like $30 a year not $60 a year
who knows maybe take that 60 go
somewhere else with that yeah absolutely
absolutely i mean the only way what they
have now know you might even be pushing
it well if that's the thing like that's
the thing i think that we don't really
know what's going to be included in that
i mean they could have some killer
features that we had we don't even know
that could make matchmaking easier can
make group forming easier and yeah it's
on a knife it's on a mobile app yeah
that sucks but you know there could be
some compelling features that no one has
even thought of at this point then we
see it we're like okay well it makes
sense to be on a mobile app although I
mean you can ask the Lord's I've been
very okay with them making it on a phone
up because we've never seen that it
could be so innovative that other people
adapt to that it still I don't want
nobody at the Xbox
thing like I don't use my phone to play
video games
it's Ivan you it's using your phone to
like party in jail like I get that you
know the other the competition they have
more you know centric one that's on
their consoles but I'm not saying that
you know Xbox is gonna like cancel the
you know that there's if there was an
add-on than fine if it was okay you
could use this as well that's good you
don't want engine seated no I do not
want to use a companion my phone as a
companion to my console Oh to be your
bill to the bone no it's not nothing
this is the computing power that see
there slick there no they know that this
system is not as strong so what we're
going to do is use your powerful phone
CPU and we're going to use that to
dedicate this to offload debt that we
have nothing to worry about on this side
at all so it's just afferent again don't
defer you should have built that inside
your system no I don't think that is a
good idea at all but that's just my
opinion I will not be participating in
that I will be the mute players in the
whole situation loaded oh no I want to
get back to real quick um it's far as do
no use talking about that roughly arms I
also want to stand corrected cuz Lord
rule is in a chatty actually a good
point we a stand corrected on it is not
an official III press conference from
the tech it is after obviously a direct
right it should right showing it so all
showcase we talked a little bit on for
guys this week on Thursday about
Nintendo whether or not that's a big
mistake because you know at first you
saw people pulling out of e3 so I
Activision EA they did their own things
but at least EA has a conference to get
the hype going at least you know people
like devolver digital now they're gonna
have their own III conference and I
don't think they're gonna meet any three
I think they're gonna do the same thing
they always do that little you know
cookout trailer kind of thing they have
across the street and think they rented
somewhere they're gonna have other
fronts
that's what hasn't Ubisoft that's better
and horrible so sort of like you know in
my opinion I think that it's a mistake
for them not to have a conference
like you said at the beginning at the
onset of this this topic they have the
lead in terms of hype they have the NPD
numbers they are selling like hotcakes
you can't find them anywhere why not
continue that helped by having live
people on stage having live people from
third parties endorsing your products
someone from EA somebody from Ubisoft
these people on stage and doors can
instead they're gonna have the dull you
know what like I want to watch in an
hour and thirty minute video you know
that's my biggest retro but Nintendo
Direct it live people get me hyped
videos to uh necessarily get me hyped
that's a good point because they
actually did their reveal that way right
and it got a lot of flack you know
because you know we all know culturally
sometimes it's you know some things came
off a little wacky you know as far as
and well first of all God bless the
translator remember the fiasco yeah yeah
it did Oh reveal all or like I think it
was when he got to Sudha and he was
describing one of his games and I
believe the UH they distract later could
not keep up what was going on so it was
just like a mess but oh yeah I hate what
you saying about like a static video and
stuff like that that sometimes it does
lose that effect so I hate you on that
but uh Lord ohm II bonta's gonna get
your feel on Nintendo as well oh man
well you've stole my Thunder with uh my
big mic drop but yeah I'm honestly
really curious to see what they do with
Mario though I mean my Odyssey I've had
more fun with a lot of Mario games than
I ever thought I would over the years
between Mario 64 like diving into that
when I was a kid just getting me hooked
Mario Brothers 3 like Super Mario
Brothers 3 still when the greatest games
I've ever played
oh that's what a lot of people you know
they keep saying oh another Mario game
look like I'll be the first to tell you
Nintendo uses that Mario IP a lot but
this isn't your average Mario game
there's not been a whole lot of 3d
marios out there nope so this I think
like what this is the fourth one again
64 you had galaxy
what sunshine listen to
still today was one of the WiiU but
people tell me they don't count it I've
never no decade for the WiiU is
fantastic
no really is one of those gonna sit
there with just any of the rest cuz
honestly the perspective maybe like two
and ashlynn yes that's fantastic
that wasn't complete for people at the
same time I mean I'm really tired of
people bagging on the wheel it was a
good system just marketed home it wasn't
even like the way the reason the way you
fell is because of you know bad
messaging and because Nintendo gave up
on it so fast what happened to the Xbox
- we have bad messaging but we change
directions we fire people and we put you
know filling space and fill us out to
this thing baby that's right fill out
this chat like the Sun baby go ahead
feel okay loading boxes did you get a
chance to our caste Nintendo Direct this
week in reference to children - and arms
I was like we looked over some of the
arm stuff I mean I didn't see too much
on splatoon I didn't get into splatoon
as much never kind of got around to it
but I know I've has me intrigued a
little bit but as you guys were saying
when it comes to the price point then
one of those things on something in
single games I feel like they could have
more success if the price point wasn't
the full $60 game I mean some of the
games like once usage if it was I don't
know three derived not know how packing
what a package yes but even if it wasn't
the full like fish if it was like twenty
or thirty I feel like they were just
solving by the truckload even digitally
just so people could have it is that
party game just to have it because it
would be cheaper as opposed to yeah it's
not that worth it up tried it like if
somebody owns a switch they should
probably be able to get that one why not
anchorman said three dollars and fifty
cents is all it'll pay for you know a
man go they go ahead will bring them all
out I can't wait for fallout I can agree
the ones I really wait for [ __ ] savages
baby fallout will make it look better
anchorman fallout 1 he's waiting for
fallout work yeah
yeah movie guard uh no but arms is
interesting just like the more you can
watch it as you guys were saying it
wasn't one that I had a whole lot of
thoughts are really about the more you
look into it as like this could be fun
if you find the right group to play live
with it was what I thought it was like
30 bucks but the more assault that's on
that price tag like don't get me wrong
it's like it's like little Cognito said
like mitten games but it's like if you
compare splatoon to like a first-person
shooter or even third person that it is
it's like can it compared with the same
price tag it's something like destiny to
call a duty
yeah I mean those are just on different
levels and unfortunately Nintendo just
has their pieces but I mean splatoon was
insanely popular so oh yeah definitely
my everyone I've talked to they said
it's it's good it's a really good guy
yeah like they love it so but I mean
arms could be one of those things where
it just kind of hides and slowly builds
the more people that hear about it
like one of those as you said if they
listen like giant bomb I listen to their
podcast and some other one but it's just
like it's those ones when those people
really get their hands on it and they
dig in and they've got all the
experience out there you know touching
so many different places when they get
in to actually you know get their hands
on arms if this is heck got that little
perfect Nintendo touch on it just like
so many other things do it cuz it's just
waiting to see it if it has the Nintendo
touch just like Mario Kart just like
Mario it's like they're Magic Erasers
it's like just a Nintendo magic will it
be there and that's usually what makes
you break so much of those stuff alright
so here uh real quick I just went before
lady Ponder's over that I just want to
get I know in front of stucked solist
under a little bit with the metro as it
as a mic drop moment for them or what
else would you be excited for I know you
said Mario to but anything feel like
would just put the hammer down for
Nintendo as well at this uh this direct
heavy okay
pokemon on my switch it's all I want
okay okay on my switch like you give me
like the other you go throwback to red
and blue or if the current ones are Sun
and Moon if you do stars whatever it is
give me a new Pokemon where I can just
like chill and hang out and do that and
just have my little like Pokemon to go
but in new high def yeah I'll get that
one so I mean that's that's alright
here's a
like it would you want to talk about
conversion rate for Zelda it'd be a
hundred percent on Pokemon absolutely
hey do you think do you think you guys
they would pull act they can pull that
gun out at 83 Oh would you think is
premature you think they might say I say
that's a little like well I mean I guess
they've got spittoon they've got arms
but those are basically coming
relatively soon both of them you're only
big things at all and that's Mario and
while Mario's big you could at least
build the hyper so hey like hey if you
want you know get your switch now you'll
have Mario you'll have a few things
maybe in the spring say they do that
March release for Pokemon out of that
big sell before their financials go out
something like that and kick off the
spring and summer with Pokemon so people
can have it with them wherever they go
so I don't know but I'd be interesting
to at least tease it at least your
motion that it's out there would plan a
seat I think pretty well I think this is
one of those very few scenarios or
gamers are like I don't want to know
game that's coming out three or four
years and you know one of the biggest
speculation to the to the switch is like
are they going to drop support like they
did on the Wii U so like this is not are
the only times that I think it's okay to
come out to be like this is coming out
the year after next an attack so uh look
King I know you uh switch gang in it oh
yes of course
what is going on with those predicts
would you heat from Nintendo right now
what do you like everybody said we all
want Metroid I don't care what anyway
says anybody you know system we already
know Mario's coming we already have
Zelda which is a bone because usually we
wait once we get a system for Zelda for
three years you know with each system so
the fact that you know we got it the
first day that that's a boon for us
that's like oh what now we playing
warehouse money because we knew he was
getting Mario so um and then Mario car
came out was fantastic so yes
everybody's looking for that Metroid my
thing with the Castlevania 2d
Castlevania like a Super NES remake with
a better graphics you know so no Virtual
Console you want to chill remaster
message I want I'm gonna truly master
like they did um wonderboy
uh okay yeah so do it like that I'd it
wit with a nice little
flare to a simple cartoon graphics like
they're doing the Bomberman was fun to
it that I got so I really think that
Nintendo can just happen to the old IPS
that they had before I mean I think they
still own the rights to that um
Castlevania Konami put out because it
wasn't on anybody else's system so you
don't remake that game put that game out
or give me the new a crazy oh oh
yo y'all made me digging the crates
crate in the basement okay I see I see
it Lord Louis I've been quiet there with
you and your Nintendo predictions and
also what's your feedback on I know me
and you've had some offline discussions
and reference to that arms you tend to
direct so where we at with being with
Nintendo yeah like in terms of the
direct like I gotta let you like I told
you earlier it um it kind of changed my
view on the arms and the splatoon arms
or something that really wasn't paying
much attention to um and then after this
direct like just to see that all the
modes that are in it and it's gonna be
it's gonna be giving people more than
just the head-to-head fighting um
obviously the fighting seems like it's a
little more in-depth also than than what
it initially appeared to be so that's
interesting again it to me it showed me
enough to at least warrant a look so I'm
definitely um when the test-fire goes on
the next couple of weeks I'll definitely
give it my final kind of yes or no
whether I'm purchasing day one but again
it just seems it has that Nintendo
polish uh that that that they're known
for and they always find a way to make
their things fun and from what I've
heard so far it's the first game that
really makes use of the rumble and the
motion in a way it took down the switch
where it feels like it's warranted and
feels and it feels good it feels like
it's responsive so if they're really
able they're really able to to kind of
avoid that I think I kind of have a hit
on the hands as long as they give people
enough mode to keep them engaged I think
I think it's going to be a big deal the
only thing that worries me
that why release it on the Friday after
eat yeah yeah glad you mention that I
felt the same way it's kind of weird
don't you feel like maybe kills a little
momentum it does because everybody's
coming back from e3 the press is coming
back from e3 tired like yeah you know
and they have to worry obviously not
everybody from all these outlets is
going to e3 they'll have people in the
offices playing the stuff and and and
trying to get reviews out but but still
it's just one of those things like maybe
given another week removed from e3 so
people are back you know into normal
routines and relaxed and kind of are
able to give it the time that it
deserves um so it that worries me a
little bit because it almost seems like
it's they're not 100% confident in it
but again it just might be a just a
foolish decision on their part in terms
of that but I think the game the game
seems like it's going to be good enough
at least to kind of open some eyes um
okay and in terms of splatoon splatoon
was another one that I really wasn't
invested in on the Wii U um I saw the
draw to it I saw in what people liked
about the fact that it was a different
take on a third-person or FPS um but for
me I needed a story one I needed
something substantial and that's what
they showed me in this direct but for me
again
I may not be that invested in the
multiplayer aspect of it but what I saw
of the single-player was cool enough and
I hope there's enough of it to warrant
the purchase but for me it kind of once
again it's like it's something where
I'll see you know how it pans out when
it releases and decide whether to
purchase it or not but again the
single-player stuff had me intrigued um
so yeah they're there honestly so that
said when it comes to e3 they need to
kind of keep the gravy train rolling I
mean they really they they're going in
on a high on a very positive note this
past week they just announced uh
that I think the Friday the 15th or
something like that they're releasing
the Azzurri Azura gun ball uh that was
on the 3ds which is kind of like a
Megaman X type game okay
so we're actually getting that on the
15th so we will be able to play it on
the plane trip back home
um this is like a Mega Man X type game
that had a decent amount of success on
the 3ds they're actually putting in back
from mighty number 9 so I guess they're
trying to salvage that uh that character
by putting another person game okay so
this is the stuff like this and this is
the stuff that they sort of announced
matter-of-factly so this is the type of
stuff that I did that that's exciting
from them like every week gonna get
something new you know we didn't know
about we know about a thumper maybe -
about a week or two before it came out
so this is that extra money that keeps
the conversation interesting with them
and so again going into e3 that's the
type of cadence that I think they need
to they need to keep up in terms of
releases and stuff like that my thing
obviously Virtual Console um Virtual
Console in some way shape or form needs
to be there and and if we leave and if
we remember like Virtual Console at its
high was probably on the week and then
you're talking about not only Nintendo
systems you have the NES SNES and n64
but Virtual Console on the we also had
Genesis also had several graphics like
oh wow this is the opportunity to be the
one-stop shop for all of this retro
stuff if they get it right um not to say
they're gonna they'd have that all of
that on launch but it could be a it
would be great if they would have a
substantial amount of that stuff on
launch um obviously their infinity their
online stuff um let's see what they do
with it yeah I think they need to really
consider charging a very low amount for
this I think that you get away with
charging a lot um and I hopefully
they've reconsidered what they would
they want to give us in that package up
that whole thing about you know getting
you know one or two NES or SNES games a
month with online functionality and then
them taking the data way they're playing
it away after the month
yeah that's a consumer-friendly you guys
are too much of a high right now to
really throw that foolishness and in
tumors so hopefully they rethought that
stuff um again I'm gonna echo what
everyone else says we want Metroid why
won't my don't need that even if they
don't give up that'll be my drop yeah
get ready and go
I just want to throw this in on your
point as well and also I want to get a
lot of friends input on this as well
about this I don't know if the Lords
have heard this rumor going around shout
out the Lord will rule and chattels who
brought it up about this Zod it's for
the switch to be announced by Activision
have you guys heard this yeah a few
times okay okay what do we feel about
this do I mean if if that is the case I
mean right now is a lot of tea leaves
being circulated you know what far is
the the team I guess they posted a
picture and there was some speculation
there and um you know there is a rumor
that it could be in existence and
Activision might grow that a bone but
maybe even a separate version obviously
we don't know if it's capable of
handling you know what's what's coming
out right now for a ps4 and Xbox one but
uh what do you think just in the theory
in general if if they were to status
you'll be full all right well if
backwards compatibility is any indicator
we saw black ops to come out and you
know hit sales numbers that they haven't
hit obviously in a very long time and
and I heard that it cracks you know NPD
marks for black ops 2 so if if that's
any indication then they can do like
what you just said cog you know they can
release completely diversion or release
you know a full version of something
like black ops 2 on switch or a world at
war on the switch or something like that
and they could and they could fetch some
numbers I think it doesn't have to be
World War 2 it doesn't have to hit the
same visual the same experience as the
console versions they know it's not
going to people who have those no it's
not going to so if they get something
similar to what people are still playing
with backwards compatible titles like
black ops black ops 2 um if they can hit
an experience similar that I think then
they should do it and I think it's
almost a given that it will happen so I
absolutely believe these rumors man yeah
I mean I think that would be a go what
do you think little king and Lord I'm
gonna Attica what cures about what Your
Honor I think that it'll be fantastic
forum because you know there have been
out of that space for such a long time
that
that space is definitely needed for a
couple of their customers not saying
that all the customers that buy Nintendo
products is looking for call of duty
experience I think those people are
looking for something other than enorm
but just akkada to a few of us who will
actually probably purchase it maybe if
they're it's just zombies you know um
and you have that you know condensed
version of you know Nintendo's of call
of duty zombies people will purchase
just for that zombies because a lot of
people don't even play the campaign they
play the multiplayer is and he looked at
his armies so shout out the lady melon
from IGN and that's something we see
always give you good all the time be it
is a hardcore cult following for the
handsome definitely so I think I think
if they go in that direction and you
know they try to change the the flow to
water from going to the left to the
right in their own lane to you know to
stay away from the comparisons
don't let digital foundries get a hold
of you bro oh oh let me do it in the
book because this is not a good look for
you you got school you love that you got
that Pro bro just stay in your own lane
and they'd wanna and you you get a
little 60 frames per second doing your
thing over there and just don't allow
them to do the direct comparisons
between games this is not gonna be
beneficial for Nintendo yeah that's what
we can visit yeah it's not a more data
cube little quiet here what um you've
been thinking in reference to Nintendo
what they got cooking what you're
excited for and also I'm curious about
your opinion about the UM arms in on
splatoon - I never get an offer I guess
we'll talk about splatoon and arms uh I
still think I'm I'm gonna pass on
splatoon okay like I'm not I'm not
saying that you know splatoon is you
know a bad game or anything because I
played it it seemed fun but splatoon
just didn't seem like something that I
would play long-term specially so uh
arms uh like I was like hey all no at
first but now I'm like every time I see
you when you tell me about the direct
all the midea shouldn't wash this it's
like every time I watch something about
this game I'm like you get more and more
interesting and you know so I'll
probably pick up arms about the whole
Call of Duty thing I do think it's
coming think activision you know I do
think they'll try and my biggest thing
is like Laurel or King says it's just I
feel like it this might hurt them more
than it will help them because I feel
like it they're going to get that you
know they're gonna drop the call of duty
out and the digital foundry then we're
gonna get on it through you know
hundreds and hundreds of articles on the
internet say that they can't run Call of
Duty what else run I just like look like
I'm all about putting more product on
the switch but make sure that you put it
on there and it's at least a decent
version don't downgrade it so much that
it's it's it's like ten its Rob would
say ten percent that's exaggerating a
little bit
you know lates like sixty percent of the
console game because they downgraded
they took out modes and I'm like do not
be a Call of Duty that went for the 360
to the Xbox one and from the ps3 to the
ps4 because it will hurt you you won't
get the cells back chances are it will
hurt you in the public eye more than
will help you if enough fair enough
not here but III get out talkative to be
completely honest with you I know I'm
gonna get really I'm gonna get bitched
at for this statement let's go let's go
this with the round a half though I have
at my doubts with with my uh with uh you
know with Nintendo I feel like they're
not having a press conference not
necessarily shows you know they don't
have nut in the show because like
they're doing these directs before e3 so
I feel like they do have something they
wouldn't do these guys I mean let's be
honest people before e3 unless the other
arms could have been on stage for them
right yeah they could have did they
could have put this in the direct at e3
so right there shows that you know
they're like we want people to know what
arms and splatoon is so we don't have to
show that e3 so you know I do to
consider a Chronicle you know I do think
that the first one will be re-released I
I don't people say Super Smash Brothers
I doubt it I don't think they want Super
Smash Brothers global arms I'm cute
can I see that coming out beginning of
next year you know middle which may be
March ish um I see you know maybe a
Mario Party being announced I see this
year I see maybe you know we'll see
maybe a metro that's the best-case
scenario and if it isn't you know I see
I see they bringing a lot of Wii U ports
and that's not a bad thing because there
was a lot of good with you games that
with a lot of people didn't get a play
yep so you know I see I see maybe one
good title that they show that like you
know is that drop the mic we walk off
the stage moment and then I see a like
you know little little browse of of you
know the these we you taught us and the
people got to understand like do not go
into this direct with the intentions and
the thought process that you're about to
see some hot [ __ ] because you'll see
good games but the people don't realize
about Nintendo is they do these directs
they could drop them at any time they
could drop a direct a week later right
the only advantage I see what you going
with that low deck is that as much as I
was upset that they didn't have a
presence as far as a formal conference
one thing with these directs it seems
like they can control the message you
know they're like performing going back
and actually I'm not actually look
forward to their little direct you can't
be our live speech it's like you really
controlled a message in how you know you
want to do things so at first time has
this grandpa Nintendo beating to their
own drum foolishness but as I've
starting to see this you know it's it to
me it's really well done so yeah I do
think that Odyssey is gonna push more
units than Zelda obviously obviously
obviously you Marlo and Omar Omar yeah
and okay
let me ask you guys a question like I
know they won't do this but I think the
best-case scenario to really push out
switch units is the bundle Zelda and
they have people pick up Mario because I
feel like if you bundles out in holidays
of this year people go out there for
that bundled Zelda and then they'll pick
up Mario right beside it they're
bundling it means other I don't know
it's that's a secure that's a good sir
interesting point what do you feel what
are you feeling alone
um yeah I mean I guess I could see them
bundling I could also see them you know
just stick into their ways and knowing
people are gonna buy it
I think the only reason I could see them
bundling is that I think um I think that
they've already sold so many I think the
people who already have a switch going
into the holidays are not going to buy
zelda i think they already have it so
that's the only reason I could see them
bundling the reason I couldn't see them
bundling is because everybody buying a
switch at holidays is absolutely going
to buy Zelda to worry too which was it
hard to get because there's still a lot
of people out there that want to get
their hands on a switch but can yeah
definitely but then again you see that
switches install base on for Zelda is
higher than their install basically
action the actual screen because the
holder I'm in history that's ever gonna
happen
Oh a Nintendo get stuff like that done
only Nintendo you'll never see a halo
outsell the console so I think I think
the bundling I think to that point
specifically I think that bundling would
sell themselves short because I stole
mm-hmm
we lost in front for me it's not like I
was saying that you know they have I do
is just having the switches on the shell
trees and that's it - I think having him
present you know um not here
I mean yeah you're saying no attic it's
just I'm not saying that they're gonna
do it you know 100% but I feel like that
would be the best-case scenario to
really push our units in the holiday
we'll see I mean they got a lot of real
ways to go with that but I want to jump
in real quick Nintendo is not really
known for their bundles hello just ray
what oh yeah I mean you know it's
knocked it out the park I mean they're
in the driver's seat the way I look at
them coming in the e3 and um like I said
they can control this matches I do think
because they showed multiple tuned and
I'm arms already that they've got
something cooking as far as a splash is
concerned as far as my impressions of
arms are kind of like win-loss off
exactly it actually low data because
it's like I'd be honest when I first saw
arms variant of ever getting like motion
controls this seems gimmicky I don't
know and then my main
concern was even though like the
characters kind of have like an
overwatch kind of feel now I like the
personalities
everything seems kind of unique my thing
is there going to be enough content to
keep me playing sad game right it's just
yeah if it's just my name versus my god
my friend no I'm like it it wasn't gonna
do it and then as I watched it direct
and I'm like yeah they got basketball
and volleyball and then you know when
though that got me was like the two
different basketball you pick up the
other person and doesn't do a slam dunk
of me into know my feelings if you slam
all the side has ever seen do that yeah
that there's like out of control but
like I sort of Mose and then the one
that got me is they're doing for player
I remember like I don't know you saw
there's more King with them you tied to
your mantle own so that you and we get
to and I'm like oh oh I didn't see that
I must have missed there you've got they
just did a mode two or two and we have
we're restricted in proximity because
you have a rope tied to each other right
so when I go too far it's like it's it
looks fun as hell so I was like okay so
you got that going on and then what
really impressed me I don't know if
Laura saw I know you probably caught
this I didn't realize that like I just
thought each individual character had
their own set like it looks like these
all these arms are interchangeable right
what's ours like yeah lebay all the
other each of them has special ones that
I guess have different better properties
when you use it with that particular
character like oh they'll they'll tell
you like here's near the arm is it is
best suited to this character yes and it
just showed me like the level of
configuration it's just so intense like
you really can customize these things so
I was alright some depth here you know
what's going on and um them to meet up
the mic drop moment for the game was
when they said all future DLC and
everything else going forward it's gonna
be free
mm-hmm and I'm like okay they shown it
completely like how these are going away
from that you know paid stuff yeah and
and I love with like I believe Halo did
that I love when games there because to
me the most
you know sorry Activision which is on
Bungie got the most fracturing thing in
a community is when the the DLC is
separated right so you got a whole base
people that bought the game that either
is not willing to buy the new DLC and
now it's like you know that kind of
thing so now oh I don't have the taken
king but this person doesn't have this
you gotta grow mature the [ __ ] about
I've been I got in it like I should have
to have it to play with you guys and her
man yeah oh we got killed for them
Nintendo has been good about that with
their new IP I think they realize I can
order to get people in the door they did
it with splatoon where it spittoon
launch very kind of bare-bones and then
little by little they kept adding stages
and whatnot and more guns and stuff like
that but it was all free so you keep
people invested from the very beginning
I think doing that would onto the smart
thing you know that way again people
that are kind of on the fence it makes
them a little more apt to look at the
game a second time I don't recall they
did that with Mario Kart I don't know if
they made people pay for Mario Kart Wii
U in terms of lady yep yeah state yeah
so lucre and with zelda on the one
breath of the wild when I saw there was
a season pass for that at launch I was
like yeah we gonna we had DLC for this
system but I'm glad to see that pretty
much everything else has gone for a so
and to be on G I am secretly looking
forward to that DLC I mean I just got my
master so I know I'm Lee I just see what
people are planning he was like I was
like man it was an emotional thing today
that quest was baby into me I was like
yes this is amazing so now the reason
why I was so hyped to get it was because
when I read the DLC contents and they
talking about that trial of the sword
thing and that beat it in the DLC you
unlock the true power of the masses or
something that's so now so like this is
given so you know to me I'm kind of hype
for what Zelda listen anything that
gives me more Zelda content Lisa Monaco
playing bro you know at least at
single-player where it's not gonna
fracture the community like you said you
know it's just giving you more of a
single-player experience which is good
yeah and like like you said on fire I
mean you can make the argument you know
they got the best thing to play with
that that title and Mario Kart and Mario
Kart rides me how much I'd have passed
it again I did not believe I was gonna
have that much fun with but just
wrapping this up for you know as far as
the my drop moments Virtual Console
please you know we are you know [ __ ]
time owned I know but if we can do that
Metroid would be cool I would love a
cool third-party IP like a co D would be
great for the casuals I think that would
be awesome I'm here in EA has it's gonna
throat and annoying again and my mic
drop for me
I know the loud we might not agree with
this if they can get a mad and running
on that I think I don't think if they
can I just think whenever EA feels like
I think they said they're gonna do
something right they said we we know
they have the FIFA line but sports games
though do really good on the switch yeah
really good like sit in bed play game
bed and go to sleep I would actually
really enjoy that to just like go for
seasons more more of the single-player
so it's like what me and more Cognito
talked about you know actually like one
of the biggest things that they really
need a push is is when it comes to third
party you don't necessarily need every
third party but you really need to go
out for the ones that are really
portable right we definitely know you
ain't cooking something it'd be
interesting to see you apologize see the
the screenshots that they have for
Scorpios version the back we're not
gonna compare happen I mean this is well
this is my fear like don't do that don't
put in with it I feel we we're looking
but in fairness to them like when you
see like the latest digital foundry
stuff like they did the don't broke up
now granted we know thumper is not you
know it's it's dumping her you got that
you got Minecraft you know actually I
wanted a shout out I don't know if a lot
Inferno saw this and all for sorry the
the snake pass held up right well yeah
version Thank You Man Game of the Year
so what I'm seeing is when they use
unreal unreal really scales down pretty
nicely because even NBA claim about they
got a little glaze to it though and
I'm not fair hello little smearing I
think the portable part makes that
justified to sacrifice yes I think so I
think so but I don't do that making
little madam for them some little inner
corner Madden you will they are but it
has go mad and go like something like
that no man and go mad and on the go
like oh man it looks like you're gonna
go really that is gonna be better than
the goat Edition any better than that
and kitchen seriously hey quick question
you know I know we're not really talking
about Madden do you think having Tom
Brady on the cover like that my art it
sounds a little bit no I'm scared for
Tom Brady's legs what we make no don't
talk don't talk about a Bostonian near
ya stop the station review look let's
not make this guy not that special but
we will die it's so the Great Lord
inverter or anything I just know that
he's got a lot of haters I don't follow
football oh my god - donors also gonna
have respect he is still talented
exactly gotta give them in to shame [ __ ]
little about it on me hopefully the
Madden curse get ahold of him the day
time a Jets fan thing we've all got some
see what they got the momentum they got
a lot riding you know the balls in their
court you know and uh it's gonna be
really interesting to see on indirect
goals and what they view in subsequent
so I want to get into it as we know we
got the big one coming up now which is
the destiny true game play revealed and
as the iron Lord podcast originated as a
destiny focused hot ass could not wait
to have my brethren on avanti's for this
but I do want to start off different I
want to start off first with just
impressions of the actual
itself we're getting too controversial
that stuff later just about what we saw
I want to start off with sovereign
sharping you first because as we all
know lost sovereignty a destiny player
get the new battle away fast deadly
brother I am curious more Cognito is
furious after seeing it brutally honest
in revealing the Jesus yeah where you at
after seeing the Destiny team gameplay
review ok well um just coming off of
speaking on destiny one the only reason
I fell off was obviously because I
didn't have the opportunity to play with
you guys as much so I found myself alone
because I never had anything against
destiny I actually enjoyed it a lot um
it's just a matter of playing with
people so that said destiny to when I
saw the campaign the homecoming game
play revealed graphically it was amazing
by the game what they were what they
managed to do and to something just a
big of complaint people had about
original destiny is that the story did
it apart from taking king or not the
story just didn't resonate his story was
kind of looking obviously from the very
beginning here you see that the story
has it
it emphasizes characters and emphasizes
personality it gave it kind of like a
sort of a gravitas and obviously what
was happening there with it with the
tower being destroyed um I I thought
that was amazing I thought I was making
I'm obviously looking at it um you know
that's running on a high NPC and it's
nothing and we'll get into that later
bad controversy yet we don't we just do
it
but that was amazing to me honestly if
if the entire campaign holds up like
that I'm in whichever which way I'm able
to play with the middle of the night
middle of the day whatever whenever I
get a chance to vote you guys I'm gonna
be on so I'm definitely excited by that
okay all right now Lord inferno I'm
better choice first let me get your
history did you play destiny were you
not a fan of it like what getting your
destiny
nor inferno history well if there's any
well the history is very short gentlemen
I must say my impression destiny at the
beginning was a turn-off to me I did not
find the story or the storytelling
very compelling so I was very quickly
turned off the latest stuff almost had
me going back taking King Rhys vine that
stuff looked like they were you know
making strides to change how how it all
went down and um you know I was starting
to get to get back into it but you know
not not terribly um you know immersed in
it because like sovereign just said you
know you gotta have the people there to
play with I think single-player wise
it's just not very compelling so if you
got people got you crew you know you
guys of course make up your crew and you
guys are very seasoned in it but you
know bringing a newbie in you know uh to
a crew of level 40 you know light
whatever you know it's it's you know
it's very difficult to do that so it's
you know you gotta be a lot in the same
level I think destiny to kind of in the
reveal talked a little bit about how
they gonna alleviate that a little bit
so I mean I'm in for destiny too I think
I think I'm gonna buy day one um whoa
yeah I think I think that's a one yeah I
had des anyone pre-ordered I played a
good amount right at the beginning and
then you know kind of fell off like I
said because the story but I gotta say
I'm really intrigued by what they talked
about with you know doing treasure hunts
activities and stuff not have to go back
to orbit select missions know everything
there's a lot more to kind of it there's
a lot more to do and there's a lot more
that you do that pertains to a story
that's being told very well so the
storytelling I know was huge for them
they talked about how there's three
things that they wanted to kind of um
you know get going and the Sun this
release you know they wanted a world
that pulled you in I'm reading this
exactly how they said it actually a
world of pull you in amazing things to
do and always somebody to play with and
if those three things are accomplishing
destiny - those are my only qualms with
the first game I think the first game
the the gunplay was second and none um I
think the gangs was a dead load in front
want to have a slowly thank you for that
because shout out the Lord addict I know
he made it a very controversial video
you got a lot of flack but I'm glad that
a person who even didn't like destiny
per se you have the greatest experience
with first one knowledge the gameplay
that the mechanics of the kpop say that
I flew true it was that's me players we
don't get that a lot so I like to get
that love from the dot yeah man if
anything I'm a realist on it you know
even though I didn't like the gate the
the storytelling in the story that was
presented you know
the gameplay was just so good I mean I
remember the gunplay just being so so
fantastic I think the building is
fantastic
you know they're just gonna give me a
lot more stuff to do without bumping
back out to orbit and they got to give
me you know something that will keep me
going keep me driven to to get going and
they got to give me a way like they like
it looks like they've done to find
somebody to play with at all times even
if my friends aren't online or if my
friends are you know twenty levels ahead
of me just give me a way to to group up
with people and do it in the crew so I'm
excited for it Casca Clarence absolutely
but did you do any of the raise in the
first or do you not make it that no raid
snow rates maybe and that's where the
gameplay of destiny really is second to
none like the gameplay you know I the
game feels row guerrilla you know what's
more looking for repetitive it's like
that it's repetitive like I felt like
you know the game is a very repetitive
game but what makes it different is you
know it's not necessary sighs you know
there are certain extra aspects of
destiny like trials of Osiris that you
lose friends over it but uh you know
when it comes to like you know III
nightfall I felt like there at the end
got kind of repetitive you didn't want
to do it could just you didn't get
nothing out of it but like I don't play
the race literally over and over again
and I feel like it never gets old
yeah the rate is definitely loaded Ferno
the pinnacle like that is what turned to
tide for me because I was with you on
destiny won you know a lot of people
it's kind of funny I've become the
poster child for destiny but I was like
the biggest kind of Haven when it first
came
but it's home you know it's kind of
interesting what you said because I
heard that in looking yeah that's right
you go all the rage I like your bed in
the corner with this great object and
just shoot when we tell you to
absolutely meet with more cheating like
sinister you know Lord addict they beg
me beg me I really had no incentive to
talk I didn't either at it beg you
nothing you got me into the game after
you're in the game oh you're right
you're after fact I'm sorry you are
correct now I got my timeline next up
but um yes like looking or Cindy and
they really said look you've got to do
array just to see anything when you
experience that level of cooperation and
teamwork with six players and it's the
hardest content it's something - it's
nothing like that like there's nothing
in gaming in my opinion that replicates
the read experience in destiny so I'm
kind of setted you to get a chance to
but why should you you run this on this
one I will get the chance to because
they talked about how it's going to be
available to all players you know the
trials race I thought all that stuff is
going to be available you know right
away for everyone essentially um so like
it's see that's that's what I wanted I
don't want anything locked behind these
ridiculous levels and I understand you
know they are difficult I understand
that you know like like you guys said
certain modes will make you lose friends
um be careful of the wording that they
said because they just told you that all
the rage is available to you all the
rage is available to you before but it
wouldn't make any sense if you layup
level one and you can grind or rate
you're gonna make it ride easier but
you're still putting work tax gonna put
a network to get into that rake because
everybody is the you know of ice cream
on or the cherry on top of the cake or
whatever you know that's a good part in
the funny thing about destiny is like
you know you see this cooperative aspect
from like YouTube videos and stuff it's
like I said in my YouTube video like you
see what I'm doing now on the screen but
you don't hear the party that is being
taught what we're doing this is fun
because yeah I remember what orgs came
out and people kept messing up the job
but it's like look it's counterclockwise
it's not that hard do I have to get my
little brother the company and do this
don't make fun of the Warlocks with
I think that we move on please I just
would get down when I switch gears Thank
You Inferno since our naturally to my
men lordy POTUS I represent the other
side what was your feeling when you saw
the gameplay reveal I mean I'm biased
I'll say that right up front
I've got like 1800 hours in this game
sell destiny objection
yeah no honestly like everything from
what I've seen so far I was like I agree
with most of what you guys have been
saying we know the story was light we
know especially in Disney one vanilla
for sure the story was questionable and
that's being nice
of course the time you know don't have
time to explain what we don't have time
to explain it seems like at the time it
definitely seems like they now have the
time which is good because that's what
we wanted and then just the idea of when
the Cabal comes and just the premise of
the entire story spoilers but if you
watch the review you're gonna get the
same thing the motivation behind
dominus call his motivation just women
be like the traveler you got it wrong to
tell some it to have the you know
audacity involved to say anything want
that level got it wrong and that no you
got it wrong where the were the best in
the universe or how far we reach the
galaxy at least and to say we are the
ones who deserve to be Guardians we have
the ones who deserve to be empowered
with the light and we're going to take
your get we're going to control you and
show you that you picked the wrong ones
that motivation for an for a villain is
up there like that's one of the best
ones
what I've seen is it that alone doesn't
play really cool let me ask you this
question though what did you feel I
don't want to almost feel it's my own
point but I gotta ask what did you feel
about social I do what there's a Bala
performance oh no like the opening when
it's a first I had the ocean with just
him as a guardian like you see him
almost learning just getting taken down
and then picked up again in kind of the
way we did it's like we had our wipes
and things like that and it's to the
level that he's at now when you actually
see him holding the bubble
which I want one that big by the way
ours is tiny but when you actually see
him fighting and struggling taking those
missile shots and you see like the
strain in him when he's doing that just
the emotional depth that like was
portrayed in the opening cinematics Kade
so you still his little you know snarky
Budd
which is fine he mailed out a Golden Gun
and you know goes to shoot the ships and
then I Corps of course saves him that's
nice but say how does it feel to have a
warlock like a Korra have to save Cade
he was about to get squashed like he's
about to die
yeah so I was like but all of those I
mean I don't know and then the fact that
I kind of think Titan on Titan is kind
of hilarious but when you actually get
him on Titan just the fact that he's you
know got this existential crisis like
what have I been doing for this time now
that's been ripped away have I been like
so so much hopefully we can dive into
and then the fact that hope if there's
in-game lore behind all of this now I
was like honestly initial impressions
for me our two thumbs up yes I'm biased
but if they can live up to what they
showed if the healing of the missions
and throughout the campaign of course
everything can have that opening like
insanity right you can have that build
and you can have the climax and if the
missions actually you know tie a strike
into something that matters and then do
some more missions go on your side
quests learn something about the side
bring that back in if all of it ties in
together as opposed to here's this thing
here's the traveler here's the stranger
we don't know anything about it in a
raid that doesn't really connect if it
goes together and ties together a lot
more the way taking King kid but to like
the 10th level yes sign me up close eh I
mean I was I was streaming the streaming
the reveal and kind of doing a recap and
everything I just had it on my twitch
stream and everybody was just saying you
know throne run me up my money at the
screen I'm actually doing it this time
like I mean those were the feelings if
they can hold up to it so without
getting into too much detail about
specifics and weapon systems and things
like that those my impressions so far
they'll see you precious yeah they loved
what they did
done so far I'm down absolutely sounds
good now what a switch key is again
I went to rigor those like laughing I
want to get to my floor right now around
town I'm very curious yeah I'm gonna go
right after King City I'm biased as well
um but I'm jaded talk to you alright
look so um full disclosure um I'm going
to get both versions the PC version an
Xbox version full disclosure
okay you want that forty sixty but then
yeah but the thing is I might um cancel
the PC version once that's confirmed
that you know Scorpio is doing the sixty
frames in the single-player um now the
window reveal started I said hey they go
again it is so again with this CGI crap
a hundred it go again and then it
started and I said okay alright then
they came out in there like it I'm just
tired of their lies so it's just like a
salesman running his same rhetoric at
you you're just like hey goes here yeah
Honda car has what mmhmm yeah what does
what again yeah it's close can I please
drive the car and then they started the
gameplay mm-hmm and I said you know it's
the same control type of thing it was
you know staged thing but it was actual
gameplay thank you this is what I'm here
to see items come fall thank you very
upset not to country you were very upset
if the initial reveal because it was all
CGI yeah this is okay I got you
congested this is why the meat potatoes
where my money's going to cuz I can't
play no Silicon Graphics crap alright
just so much cash is going and I already
know that gameplay is good so what we're
doing is looking at story at the same
time I'm looking at the gameplay I'm
trying to see what separated them
because they are unshackled now you know
from the 360 Playstation 3
where's that horsepower going let me see
now some totally different from you
looking from a live streaming because
you're not going to get the actual
fidelity of the game to come through so
what you're looking for is little tell
things so what I was looking at the
shells the bullet ricochets the textures
on the walls that I can discern at that
point in time the animation of the
characters and about that don't bleed
don't let me get to the powers of each
character after that and what I was
doing was taking in the nuances of the
graphical engine that they're using now
opposed to the old graphical engine and
you can see that there is a discernible
difference in animations of the
characters so I was like okay I like
that
and then I noticed that it was um it was
grounded because uh the the the particle
effects and it was uh what's that word
on just Jesus funny yeah it was the
physics okay physics of a box that he
had shot he had shot something as the
war and the physics of the box
tumbling I was like oh they actually
using a lot of physics engine is it a
havoc engine or something like that and
I said wow okay I can see the processing
power now I see it so I was I was happy
I was amazed from that point on I didn't
really want to see too much but I wanted
to see the new powers and when they got
to the most impressive power to me was
something with a shield of Calculon
remaining gone agrees with you know that
I said Tom I said I'm a Titan this year
making the Titans first they had Thor
thank you good night yes that we got
that we got captain Barry I will say one
day know when he used that on the the
fist of havoc at the in that trailer or
here looking down the hallway he saw
like eight covered Adam and his hand
started glowing I was like I know
exactly what he belted too good look
when he used the shield and the bounced
off of all the enemies and singing back
down I said is on now and I went and I
proceeded to stop looking at
you for a second to pre-order my jump
ball and jump back to the video I said
oh let me get the hundred dollar Disher
cuz I'm not gonna miss out um it
impressed me mm-hmm
it impressed me and that's what I wanted
to take away from it I wanted to take
away a level of being impressed and
enthusiasm that I had for the first one
now are they gonna live up to the lies
that they tell I don't know do I have
hope yes I do because the story look
like it's more fleshed out hopefully
they don't fire people two weeks before
the game is coming out all that stuff
yo yo yo lose you know the whole Peter
Dinklage situation that won't ever crop
up again um I don't know I feel that you
know they're gonna make it easier for
your friends to join you there removing
the barriers of the old systems as far
as having to go to space and having a
loading and having it wait around are so
they took away those barriers and I
thought those barriers was brought upon
by the old gen okay so all we're looking
for and a Scorpio uses because we know
that the PlayStation grow we go get it
yeah yeah it's a situation that's a good
ya know negra he's easy job little bit I
just want to finish it with addict um no
doubt no but I was impressing me
and I think it cool fair not fair Dark
Lord addict when you saw that trailer
you were very quiet in that chat with me
I need to know what what the feels
alright first so uh first off I want to
going to say that I was in with that
trailer the moment I saw the ball I put
up that shield was like on me I was like
yeah like that's that's the only time
you've actually seen him have any kind
of emotion cause he look he's sitting
there walking towards the UH that big
window that's behind the Vanguard and
then you know I thought it's kind of
funny how ironically he decides to look
at the one at the moment
oh yeah pick a partner decides this to
descend on the arm on the tower and he
what he said that day and then you know
he puts up that bubble I was like yo
like this is a good why first off they
started it with him girl growing up to
becoming the Guardian and that was a
really good way to get people into that
into the actual gameplay trailer so then
you see that and then for some reason I
don't know you know that it's K for you
but Kay decides to use the Golden Gun
when their ships that he's fighting and
not him and I'm like and when I saw that
I was like what you doing Kate and then
you know that homegirl say don't like
you don't want for that stupidity I
would have been out I would have been
upset if he got crushed because like it
makes no sense to me little whips up
that's coming at you he uses a Golden
Gun beat us that's either that's that's
neither here there so then you get to
the gameplay alright so you go up to the
stairs then you see that you see the UH
all those little I don't know what
they're exactly gonna call them those
little capsules that the the Cabal in
them he like white when they destroy
every vault that was in front of me so
you know I first thought that was good
then you get to the portrait of Allah
you know he puts up his bubble again
because they're shooting those missiles
at you and I'm senior looking at this
bubble you know in the first destiny
when when you put up the bubble it was
kind of like you know it was it was a
contrast blue regardless what happened
but on here
it's like particle effects and one that
when the bubble is taking damage you see
is starting to crackle and add one more
a little bit so first I noticed right
there that you know they've really taken
into fine detail the Super's now huh
alright so at this point we've seen that
the current supers so we're going down
there and in that in the death when we
see the shield you could ask Laura cocky
I was like is that a shield you know he
throws it I was like whoa is so you know
at this point I'm already like I want
this then then you saw the hunter do his
uh his little Co fiasco and and we just
thought it was the blade answer because
you couldn't really see up close to it I
was down channel five ish yeah so you
know
then you know obviously lower sinister
goes in saying that he doesn't think
that he thought they got rethinks they
got robbed again
but that's near there and then you see
that warlock jump in the air and I think
is out he got the Nova bomb or something
this dude pulls out a sword I'm like I'm
done like what I saw the sword I was
done I was bought like right in here
start shooting now sure she shooting
that fire on it and then you know when
it comes to this game I feel like the
biggest changes that happen is
multiplayer wise I feel like that you
know they really listen to the community
list of what everyone wanted and they
realize we messed up on the multiplayer
the first one we spent three years
trying to fix it but it's not fixable so
you know they went back to their roots
and people you know I feel a little
uneasy before horn every game mode I
feel like control should be six on six
and then everything else should be four
on four but you know you stay there
everyone has to Ives okay it you know so
you can't just die constantly
consistently now you actually have to
you know value when you want to get
revived and the part that issues me the
most in the part that annoys me the most
about the game you community is this
thing you know you see that the Destiny
1.5 and I'm like when this is a sequel
to the original did they expect the game
to look completely different right the
equivalent of me saying shadow war you
know looks just like shadow of Mordor at
immortal and pipe I may do the same at
1.5 it like I'm like look like there's a
difference between giving speculation
and constructive criticism and just
being an [ __ ] and that's what a lot
of people on YouTube and a lot of people
on Twitter were doing they were just
they were shooting out blind Chris and
you know when you get someone's when you
ask what what did you what did you not
like about destiny if they say it's just
trash and I'm like okay can I have a
specific reason it's just trash I'm like
oh my god
so favorite-- eggie convinced I mean is
just it is what it is you know destiny
is just one of those games that you know
it's just like the way I equivalent is
like how I got fortunately I guess I'll
call a nudie close to it some time now
when it becomes that level of popularity
I mean the stream numbers that they have
dick Ulis I don't know if anyone who
knows like 500,000 I was under something
like that on Twitter at Wow it was it
games good though my twitch stream I
don't know if it was that or was beat by
the Xbox app and that's every time I
watch it
that's just quick imagine people
watching on YouTube to game saw through
IGN you know they split up the install
base on YouTube like you know that is my
biggest thing is look they messed up on
the story there's no denying that you
know they they had to do a lot of
last-minute [ __ ] on destiny doesn't
excuse it should have been delayed if it
was that serious they did a lot of
questionable marketing on the first one
doesn't excuse it but on the second one
you know you had taken king they were
like look we get it we're fixing this
we're trying to put more aspect on the
story wise they put it works in there
you know they Railly gave if they gave
ke to voice so like we're getting that
you get rise of iron get solid in a
voice you know you're like we get mad
it's like son to flesh out characters
yeah it's like look like I feel like
people really look down on the on the on
the the negative aspects on destiny and
Bungie but they're not looking at how
they're improving the game how there are
three years destiny vanilla and destiny
rise of iron were two entirely two
different different game absolutely well
in in the people's defense that hate
destiny we do have to give them this
that sometimes that first impression can
leave a sour taste oh look at Xbox one I
will you know I don't want to make you
know obviously y'all know Destiny's my
favorite game but I do want to
sympathize with them in that but like
you said Lord Atticus it's one of those
things that is like if you haven't
played it especially from the taken King
on cuz Lord of boxes would know that's
when you know when Luke Smith Mike knows
mark knows worthy and those guys really
got in changed the lighting system you
know the like leveling system and so
many different mechanics and getting
started change but I'm gonna jump in
real quick I do want to say one more
thing though I think it's it's funny how
of my have destiny and Bungie in the
amount of three years has almost
arguably enough hate that card has had
in the past 15 years yeah it's up to
it's up that is there's definitely a lot
of dislikes but um let me jump right on
this I'm with the Lords on all this on
blew me away
shut up the Lance Reddick you know
that's my man from the ylo King knows on
you know it's been around for years and
I really wasn't the biggest of ala guy
you know to be honest from the character
standpoint mmm intro made me fall in
love with the character and it was to me
very spectacular the first time I felt
emotional watching it that's deep
anything else is like now granted I may
be fanboy and out that may be my own me
in my feelings but I thought that
initial scene with him being woke up by
the ghost defining what it means to be a
guardian and how killing that to me was
amazing symbolic loved it the whole the
whole ride I was in on the whole ride
real quick synapses on the powers you
know son Singh is my thing a warlock so
to see that transformed into an
offensive super with a sword look
spectacular to me completely amazed all
the social features as you know Lord
addict mean the you and Lord sleeve
going back with us why but I was just so
happy that for the people like you know
infernal and sovereign who never got a
chance to do a rade never got a chance
to do it I never say that there's more
tonight cymatics in this game than
they've ever done like that to me I mean
you've got the best content destiny not
like 10 percent the numbers would never
ever get a raid and to me that was your
said so I'm finally glad that they got
you know they got that straightened out
created the guided games you know and to
me was amazing so and the last thing
about the patrols the maps you know
multi-player changing up when a for
before looks like from a balance
standpoint look like they go in the Halo
route and at first I may have felt a
little in my feelings because it wasn't
six but I'm like you know what if they
can balance this thing I'm okay with
that and I'm also curious to see how
trials is going to play Montes when arms
all modes of all extra person is very
vital and trial that's gonna be
interesting in Canyon at Natick so um
that's pretty much me with the
impressions now I want to get right in
to the controversy cuz we know Destiny's
Fox some stuff this week so again I want
to bring it to a lot Inferno now now
that we know the ps4 Pro is doing 4k 30
all consoles are doing 30 frames
as of right now Bungie has yet to
comment on what the Scorpio version is
capable of most likely due to NDA but um
the question becomes Mike Ibarra has put
out a statement this week stating
because one of the biggest fears from
the Scorpio community was would Xbox
games be held back Scorpio games be held
back based on Kari
I prefer genius or might do but that was
Mike Ibarra dropped a bomb this week on
Twitter it's amazing how a simple tweet
just put so much light on stuff and
basically said this is not the case we
do not demand parity it is up to the
developers Lord inferno I need to do
your impressions of this whole fiasco
the Scorpio dudes the PC court the
differentials in 30 frames per second
what did you feel when you got this
plethora and I know you saw my timeline
because my timeline was lit on Twitter
that was yeah so I need to know your
feelings on everything controversial and
and and honestly you know when it comes
to first-person shooter games give me 60
FPS over 30 whatever you got to do so if
you got a if you got to make it 1440p
like and you got to keep it at 1440p and
give me 60 frames per second
give me that you know I mean give me
that and you know what as far as the
Barra tweet and addict you said it you
said it pretty well it's just amazing
how much can be stirred up over a tweet
like that and just a power move by
Microsoft knowing that they've created a
console they can do these games at such
high fidelity and if you're gonna have
you know especially you know Microsoft
and Bungie are no secret here at bad
terms and so a company like that they
can show them up like that and make them
look like they're the ones that I'm
seeking it back the back-slapping
exactly it completely took the light
away from them being the reason why oh
yeah we that was a throw under the bus
comet I mean man oh yeah definitely and
then you get you get people a sham
Loftis that initial
he said that that wasn't the case in
Ashley oh no never mind you know Mike
was right thanks for clarifying Mike you
know we're gonna jump on that bandwagon
cuz we just [ __ ] you over um Kelowna
that's a good point for Clarion the
frontal assault stance on Scorpio
initially and I million Lauri anchor
male going at it a little bit and cuz
initially they did say that described Bo
titles in the xbox one would have to
have like a multiplayer frames per
second parity so race is a reverse
stance in a sense right here oh yeah
definitely because they didn't want
people in understandably so Microsoft
doesn't want people they have the OG
xbox or even Xbox 1s to feel like they
have an inferior product like
PlayStation doesn't worry about doing um
but [ __ ] for that and they're real quick
I don't I mean gonna be real when I
gotta be real but but you know I and I
understand what they're trying to do but
at the same point you know now they're
saying they don't want to do that now
they saying you know we have a beast
here you know if if we can get a 60 FPS
on a most powerful console and that's
gonna drive some sales cuz let's just
face it if destiny - were 4k 60 on Xbox
one it would be it would be a system
seller useless it would be a boy exactly
would be an amount of marking
I mean being the only place where you
can market 4k 60 on arguably the biggest
game 2017 that's a huge huge push and
and you know I I hate to think that the
reason that they're not people do that
is because stone is forcing them not to
put you up to speed little [ __ ] you
touch it's a great place though you do
know about the level of teen petty when
it comes to swinging exclusive oh yes I
do with destiny in the Xbox community
mm-hmm my question to you over do would
you put it past Bungie to have something
with Sony to not allow them to maximize
the score you wanna frames per second
Stan I I wouldn't put it past them as
Saturday I think it's pretty safe to bet
that's what happened you can't really
mark and you know you can't blame Sony
you can't market of
version of this game when the better
superior way better superior version
because you know 30 over 60 is a huge
advantage in multiplayer and it's on the
competition you kid there's no way you
can downgrade that there's no way you
can fight that unless you like look we
will not be writing these checks out
unless you do what you need to do and
because I'm good competing I'm sorry
just to go to that 30 versus 60 point
and a lot of people complaining about
that on Twitter you gotta realize that
PCs been doing this since what the
beginning of PC gaming there's been
discrepancy in FPS and no one is bitched
about it if you want it you pay five
hundred dollars you pay exact I'm I'm
which you come I'm in the Lord King
State of Mind if you pay for the premium
experience right oh okay oh oh where to
go yeah I'll get you that I'm just
thinking of your mindset I know pretty
much what I pay for and P like like not
Inferno said it if pcs been doing this
for years so we don't want to hear about
unfair advantage don't let 2013 console
hold back at 2017 so I was proud of
Microsoft with jumping in front at like
that to me was a bombshell continued on
the front I'm sorry catch no no yeah I
mean that's exactly it like 2013 versus
2017 the hardware is completely
different can you imagine if they what
the PC community would be like if they
had a whole back to like a GTX like
seven hundred likes come on and people
would be going crazy they graphics card
for a reason
you don't buy Scorpio you don't and um
you know maybe five hundred maybe four
or whatever it is if it's a it's five
hundred say if it's more you don't you
don't buy that to be held back by the
system that's come out in 2013 and I
honestly sympathize with people on this
destiny thing because I honestly when I
heard it was thirty across all consoles
honestly shocked about it honestly xiong
and nothing makes me waver from my
thoughts that it's it's being held back
by Bungie and Sony's deal I mean it's
gotta be it's gotta be there's no other
explanation
fair enough Lord King need us
perspective is vital well however
Spectre Pattie baby I respect you I
respect it because let me tell you
something if I could cap you I'm gonna
cap you they have the exclusive
marketing there aren't enough no that's
not enough
hamstring the other dude as well wheeler
had to bottle him up because he's too
robust we cannot allow this to happen
now coming from the standpoint of me
purchase of the Scorpio
I cannot stand a petty just petty stock
that must stop I must stop but do I
respect that I respect the hell out of
it um so you respect that you expect
change
Thanks I respect - Mumbai Saudi to say
oh no we can't let this go down
I respect the foresight okay I respect
the foresight that they said man well
we're gonna bring out a destiny - and
our contract will extend its destiny -
or they talk about Scorpio um we're
gonna have to go back to the table and
underrate this part right here - under
my teeth the beginning my tag with you
guys we will have this okay maybe ask
the Lord's this do you think now that
this all this hot Stern is going on
right and the facts of coming out that
it is not Microsoft do the Lord's feel
in any way that this puts pressure on
Bungie to make a better version for
Scorpio no they don't care now also get
Chris trew [ __ ] you back word gets real
quickly I would get it back to Laurie
Mel's like I was just gonna say I was
like um kind of just and standing away
on this one just because it's up just I
mean it's that's a business partnership
and when it comes down to it if they
have a business partnership and they've
agreed to it and it's in a contract and
Sony is going to be the one to step up
and pay for it I mean if Microsoft wants
to pay for it they can but if Sony beat
him to it they've got it in there then
unfortunately as a developer you got to
work with where the money's at as much
as you can so it's like take what you
can take your advantages they've already
got
blizzard and Activision behind them and
that's the bigger level anyway so me
bunch of make some of these decisions
but Activision's are really probably the
one pulling those strings and I take
those pairings up so I mean they're just
taking advantage of what they've got and
if they're gonna say this is the best
way we can sell this game to a bigger
audience in the first place and we're
gonna do it now else loading Bucks acute
you completely from one business
standpoint that's a powerful that's what
you have to that's business right yeah
my question is gonna say no ethics cuz
it's really not ethnic said but from a
standpoint of Jess you are a Scorpio
owner and you know because let's just
Buster's call it what it is Luke Smith
and walk Noseworthy when IGM fire teen
chat put the gun to the head said live
it's not strong enough like federal ID
for him they say why is it the ps4 probe
60fps and the first thing I mean Luke
just you just said if you were just like
they can't handle it no disrespect I to
reset [ __ ] for that yeah from a CEO he
said the computations in our game the
networking aspects the social aspects it
is not cable now mark tried to save and
Noseworthy try to jump in the same cell
from the resolution standpoint with GPU
they could do you know the four right so
it's a fork a checkerboard was the 4k
mater
yeah that's the other question I don't
know yes that's another question
so far it's what a finish that we
bunches so when that came out that you
know they kind of said that they put
them put them out there when you know
the gun was kind of to the head as far
as what the pro was able to do and then
the very next follow-up question from my
god Fran Mirabella you know what about
the Scorpio and then it was kind of
awkward sighs yes we can't carve it you
know it could be MBA that whole bit from
that standpoint did it at least bother
you I know you're a pro guy I know you
guys broke well I did least bother you
from a standpoint that um maybe it won't
be maximized at all that we won't see
the true potential of it from a console
standpoint on smoker I mean if I don't
say I don't even have a pro yet so
honestly it's like either way but it's
just
now I was like I've been just waiting
because I don't have a 4k monitor and I
sit down here and play them I can't hear
so say what these murmurs you can get
that ps5 before you get that pro well
eliminate long enough you know maybe
I'll do that
so oh that's all is going to say remind
me of psy for just a second one science
or this so what I was gonna say that
when you sit there and do that for one
they can't jump the gun it means bungee
litters ask to sit there and say we have
no comment about you know Scorpio we've
said it exists Joel foundry announced it
they literally cannot say anything but
it's like to know direct if I do buy the
Scorpio and say say it's not being used
but then I want to turn around and say
okay so what do they do when ps5 comes
out say it does say it doesn't whenever
say it's 2018 well geez next thing is
not going to be a short process again it
was a three year thing last time 10
years in the works were only about a
third of the way into it what are they
going to do in PS 5 comes out and then
say ok now we can do 60 FPS is that when
Scorpios like allowed to I mean that's
like a hard like that's gonna be a hard
thing to face the younger ones grew up
so now they see them on each equal to
yeah exactly it's just like how do you
decide to say okay now you're allowed to
have 60 frame per second like the day PS
8 PS 5 comes out does a Scorpio get a
patch for yes don't have to be
interesting thing I know how that works
yeah right Activision I just really
don't know
Activision analyst Corp you have 60 min
I can almost guarantee that no I was
like that's what I guess the other piece
of it is if you really really want the
good graphics wait a couple weeks get it
on PC and then just blow the doors off
of both of them not gonna be call
questions question us I'll just watch so
we're not material so I think is a year
is gonna be this year it's gonna be sick
it's gonna be the probably February
March of the following year yeah thank
you ever a PC your guys I don't be that
far
well then as equally good no dedicated
service Victoria's vixens is doing it
that sounds like you know pass it off to
this guy let that guy play around with
it I mean it look good on the pee
from the off the PC screens that I saw
but again I do not believe because
Activision wants to control the
narrative of this game they want it to
be 100% positive PC is an unknown
variable so six months or seven months
out no dedicated servers so we can blame
whoever yeah yeah I think that's yeah if
that's the way they're gonna go with it
you're not solving on a weak initiative
throughout you you've heard all the
controversy oh brother
talk to me Lord sovereign yeah I think I
got everything that the Lord have said
so now I don't think I think Activision
and Bungie or whatever that deal is it's
going to supersede anything that
Microsoft made you know would want to do
with the game it's just it's a sad thing
but again when you're the PC is a
completely different entity that they're
always going to be the superior platform
at no wait there's no way shape or form
they were ever going to have M string
the PC um so I mean yeah I think we just
gonna have to eat that on the Scorpio
unfortunately of something the Lord King
mentioned earlier which may be a
possibility maybe they let you rock out
4k 60 in single-player on the moment in
the moment you hook up with any other
Guardians that's it it drops down to the
30 arm
maybe something multiplayer centric also
when you talk about crucible maybe it
may be something in that regard
um so I mean there are different ways
that we might might be able to get an
improvement experience but I think
overall like yeah I think they have
locked on on that I don't think that's
going to change the art I see them being
that petty although um we don't
necessarily know what bungees
relationship with Microsoft is now that
Phil is at the helm it might be a little
different it might be a little less um
uh intense that it was with matric ever
at the helm so a not to cut you loose
it's enjoyed that's a great point
because I find it in law data can attest
I find it very interesting that as soon
as destiny 2 was announced and griever
comments who tweets can't wait to see
how this looks on Scorpio I mean like
how it's going to
amazing one Scorpio I also find it
interesting at a destiny - gameplay
reveal major nelson's there right he was
not on that Star Wars Battlefront Fiasco
he did ridiculous demoting elite
controller at the destiny - event talk
about this is the best licking I thought
it was the most funny what's funny is
before that whole Kong before that whole
event me and Laura cardi door even
saying they were going to do suicide
some some some marketing like that we
were like major Nelson's there watch
after this is done he's gonna be
remoting it on Twitter so it's funny
that you said they'll also because I'm
curious again we do know this marketing
deal it's definitely so that's that's
what our question but I do find it
interesting that Microsoft execs are
chirping so to speak
you know I mean okay good to jump out in
front of stuff in reference to Scorpio
and things like and to kind of put the
chest out with this course beyond this
is kind of a a bullish Microsoft right
now right like as far as the scrub oh no
no we can do this oh no you know our
control oh no you know this our version
is gonna by far like you know the best
it pretty much in so many words saying
it so you think that maybe there's a
chance as far as that relationship
something being loud possibly uh
absolutely again like I said Phil Phil
is a very diplomatic person um he's
always shown he's gotten criticism for
this uh you know anytime something
positive happens on an opposing platform
he's the first one out there to send
congratulations and I think I think that
does a lot to to sort of kind of ferment
these these great relationships with
with the other first parties obviously
because it's all gaming I mean let's be
real like all you know something is
doing well kind of lifts all ships you
know so if Microsoft if somebody weren't
doing as well Microsoft wouldn't be
pushed to do what it did to do what it's
doing now
same thing with switched which wouldn't
be doing as well Nintendo would we don't
want to go now if they didn't feel the
need to do that so um and phil has
always been phil has always been a very
diplomatic in that sense and again again
i think we don't know what that
relations
Bunji is now so absolutely I think it's
a possibility that it could be something
who knows I mean again this is something
that could be kind of revealed at e3
although again once again we don't know
we don't know what to deal with with
with so many extends to in terms of
types of media and how what you know
where they where Microsoft can kind of
come out there and say hey we can we can
be at this reveal event and we can count
our superiority in certain areas and
it's not necessarily sniping it's
stepping on right what you have written
down on paper for your deal so I'm again
if they and if they're doing it that
means that they can't because otherwise
I would be there would be a stop put to
it so literally
okay look a nine-point song okay I'm
sorry
they need to do this would read that
also when when Red Dead comes out and
then Sony has their marketing open they
need to the same thing they need the
talent you know whenever they can tell
superiority let me bring this to Laura
no I want a quite asking a question
because i t XR boys a plugged in my
question you is do you think I think
this destiny thing obviously lift the
lid off a lot right we got to see some
dirty secrets what's going on and and
how these holes go up your thing might
play as far as parody crossfire phone
whole bit do you think that this will
affect future games that Microsoft does
not have the marketing rights to well
you um we're asking that question to
Lord infernal and sadly he's not here
top-down okay so um I just wanted you
know put my little two cents in and you
know not on that topic is another topic
is all you know Sam but um do I feel
that Sony will press at any point in
time their hand on the situation yes
because of this Call of Duty ah fiasco
that was pressed upon them we forget
that Call of Duty ran better play better
on the Xbox 360 we forget that Microsoft
had exclusive
for Call of Duty for so long and they
held on to it and he pushed ahead in the
dirt and you know we're we're we're we
were the bullies kicking the strand in a
face
alright it is now I would turn to eat
this said Sam and it sucks that is on
the game that we want our stuff but it's
not going to happen because we did it in
such a demonstrative way that forced
these guys to come up with the strategy
and they came up with the best strategy
they waited for our best girlfriend to
fill this gruntled stay we waited and
they would honey water in a water when
we just said I she's not going anywhere
first just make a keep pumping out those
halos left she got sick and tired of the
sable sable any new guys driving around
in a brand new Corvette let her shop so
listen we cannot be pissed off that we
made this monster like I get that
looking but what what I mean is moving
forward never gonna be a little do you
think like for example what's Lord I got
me out here what's the other marketing
deals red dead right read them Jamie's
got um this is a battle front so do you
think that the games that Sony controls
marketing rights that these kind of
practices will continue know every boat
I don't like that everyone oh I don't
think so for one reason maybe not a dead
but I can guarantee you for Battlefront
I mean it's gonna happen there's an
action yeah it is not going to be a cap
on Battlefront that you can only run 60
cans it's already 60 right is death
that's not going to happen
did they have a little bit more entwined
with Bungie because it's a different
contract they said it when they first
did it everybody looked at the contract
I said this is totally different from
any contract that we have ever seen okay
it's
is is the PlayStation 4 is the leading
market and they will accommodate to the
leading market yeah and it's also it's
also the type of game that it is when
you look at when you look at destiny
destiny is kind of a living game you
know that you're not expecting people to
be playing battlefront two two years
down the line you do expect them to be
playing destiny two two years they'll be
the big ones I guarantee is the
dangerous one oh you don't rule let's
make it a good point though we are
forgetting the EA relationship and EA
access in that aspect like they did
there is some goodwill there there is
some things that are exclusive I
understand from the marking stamp I'm
just on my in terms of EA but II I kind
of feel it may be a little different
just because of EA access in that
relationship would formally Peter more
on those guys or you still think that
because they have it as the marketing
that this could still hinder Scorpio I
don't think it affects Scorpio I don't
not again not on the same way the
destiny thing is I mean the positive
relationship could only be can only be
seen I don't see I don't think the
positive relationship can only bring
positive things but I don't think it
would hinder it at all again like
working said I don't think it's as
deeply seated as the Bungie relationship
only brings in that this came out really
did is because destiny is one of the
only first-person shooters that doesn't
run at 60 so it there was something that
you know could be accommodated for well
let's have 60 on the Scorpio but it's
like I told you like when it comes to
these big titles the these these
developers the publishers are going to
really side with the leading platform
we've seen it with marketing those going
to them in the in the hordes as it is
not I feel I mean it's definitely a
possibility
um just whatever I look like that
they're like you know battlefront is one
thing you know it's a hit mess on that
but I guarantee you if if Scorpio is
able to hit at 60 frames they will not
do it on the Scorpio version it's
possible now I want to bring house law
recommends real late in the chat and I
don't want him to get his shine and
because this is something that I have to
admit as a destiny fan to me even more
so disgusted me was not really the 30fps
that doesn't disgust
I mean I play destiny at 30 FPS 1080p I
was perfectly fine with the get ready
gameplay so that does not bother me in
the least
however this is where I have to silent
man I kind of feel no dedicated services
kind of disgusting Oh mm-hmm
and to me this shows - I know I got
without the Lord's gotta call it how we
call it you are making hand over fist
with destiny Michael Jackson money sales
there is really no excuse you can't put
that money towards dedicated service
also that is one of the like don't get
me wrong right it's not like top three
requested community features Laurie
pontus like its way up there for
everybody I mean they could even just
Google me
that the biggest issue is just trial was
an iron banner even if they would just
do okay
heard the CEO did purchase a dedicated
server no they said they caught
interview that it was not having no no
no his dedicated server name was Ivan
and he brings his food to him all the
time we'll get on that hamster well if
that's the only thing because it's like
Kona its 2017 you know I had a pianist
like come on and then what really pissed
me off was that I guess back to the
whole Scorpio thing cuz in my mind I'm
like okay
Scorpio could still be the Dark Horse of
this destiny to thing this is pride all
the knowledge we got this week right cuz
I'm like boom they can get 4k 6000k they
could use their own in-house Azure cloud
you know said to say hey we can host it
on a throne others I think if you
remember it was it sovereign quote me on
this wasn't um Co D ghosts wasn't that
was when Microsoft still had that was
like the last year I believe they still
had the marketing rights right and they
tried to promote
that on the Xbox version it had
dedicated service do y'all remember that
e3 yeah is calling to find out it was a
lion order dated opponent like hybrid
servers vibrating recently that was gay
Xena some tomfoolery
but at least one thing I like that they
tried to do was at least try to promote
that you know from a Microsoft feature
standpoint they can do that so you know
me coming in on my okay they got you
Microsoft got some advantages that they
can use you don't want that platform and
then they hear this and I'm like what
even PC gets it like that is greed let's
call it what it is like that's BS angry
there's no excuse for that I want to
know how to Lords I was very upset
well I bought his way where was you at
with that with the dedicated service
they uh I was it was a huge letdown
because I mean that's always the big
excuse that everybody has for either lag
or this or they've got so many examples
people jumping around it's like and just
to have that not be part of it and
really get into the world of being
competitive and have people you just
have more reliable situations to figure
out it's like there's no excuses of legs
which you can just stop the excuses pay
the money have everybody just shut up
and play the game it was like that would
be one of the easiest ways to do it it's
like as you guys said Activision is not
broke Bungie isn't even close to broke
either I was like in between the two of
them they were you know they made mad
money off the desk well of course they
did just like I just don't that's one of
those I guess I just don't understand
it's like I don't know what it takes to
do it and I don't know if it's the head
like this Dhoom 4 I don't know
crucible dedicated servers just makes
too much sense that I truly do not
understand this when them when they're
not signing with Microsoft comes back
and bite them because they could have
brought the you use the cloud from
Microsoft hmm and um they would have had
all the dedicated servers and all the
horsepower that they need it it wouldn't
be any lag it would be a situation king
yes move think about you know halo I
mean for all its it looks solid burly
rush its hurts to some day aspect I
played a lot of Halo and I think I've
only had like one or two incidents where
I had like like Athena
playing and we play big batches they're
big board matches and it sucks that they
make the money they have the money and
they refuse to put the money back into
the game alright so I don't see the
benefits in me doing these micro
transactions because it's not coming
back to me it's not feeding the
community it's feeding somebody but at
eight feet of me and um that's why I
said he bought a server but um it's
gonna tell you man
I think this is this is the last one
this is the last multiplayer game that
is on a competitive level that it
doesn't have dedicated servers right
because you yeah there's a couple that
don't there's a couple I think the
battlefront doesn't either
mmm yeah that does mile out you know my
whole thing with that I mean just like I
said we had together as the Lords we
gotta keep it 1,000 one of the issues I
do have that you know it might be one of
the only games that doesn't have
dedicated service but it is probably one
of the games that that is in the first
person's honor that desperately needs
dedicated servers yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah I mean that's what I had
for on that aspect I mean obviously I
said it was it was a fun week with
destiny to on all levels from the reveal
to the head to the controversy to
everything I just thought honestly it's
crazy it was it something did upset me
we have to admit it was a fun news week
like for this it was just every day you
find out some new drama great so it
takes a lot to trigger me if I make a
bit more that takes a lot to trigger me
to make a youtube video sake shut up the
letter grid of the chase it Calvin keep
making that money I'm good shut up
Calvin at Activision for whole damn can
be hot me they're all peer to peer baby
you know not let let's talk to Microsoft
and see if they'll go ahead and talk
about dedicated servers to get everyone
hyped in the net forgive our ass is a
hood
you did challenge us with gel agree with
that we're very go back and forth but we
will always call out each Destin our
favorite game we will always call
activated my foolishness and stuff that
is it oh my god shut up soon Oh overall
we're very excited about the game we
can't wait to get it so he's gonna
finish up soon we went over with no
Destin take a while but we stink a
little bit time left I know Lord's gotta
get rolling soon we kept everybody what
a real quick Lord King yes with dupes
minced what's going on any streets oh
man so Netflix is at it again baby
Netflix is trying to add to their
onslaught of movies shows they have
brought us something that we've been
asking for and I know they're gonna do
it right
The Witcher they're gonna bring The
Witcher um I think it gets 10 episodes
and they're trying to get it going like
Game of Thrones so it's going to be
setting a type of atmosphere and I want
to know is anybody excited about it
because you know Game of Thrones came
out and it was very um how can I say in
the corner type of a niche type of show
at first and it blew up horribly crazy
and now everybody can't wait for the
next season and starting to worry about
the dragons and stuff and I want to know
is this going to be our Game of Thrones
it's just going to blow up and do we
feel a Netflix is it in good hands with
Netflix the writers you know it's in
good hands I can answer that right now
oh yeah attractions gonna be like think
about think about the iron fist that
just came out though well you know I I
must say there's a thing what you do if
I say that you've walked on a land my my
friend and it's about to blow up
oh the fact that it you know they wanted
you to slow down and think a little bit
I know it's hard some um and the
character is
very is a feeling character so you had
no feel for the character Danny Ren is a
very good character and I thought they
did a very you know did the show justice
um it's not for most like some people
didn't like Luke Cage hello okay I liked
all of them so far this one I would just
I would say of all of Marvel's showings
I will not put it towards the top if
that's they at least admit that out of
all these Marvel ones they're all good
it's just some are better yeah that was
the low end point yeah that's what
that's exactly what he said you know he
you know he said it I don't like Jessica
Jones like that and some people was like
oh that is one r39 Judi I love just a
villain adjustability and because you're
all set they said it would be great to
have the purple man's power is the
greatest doughnut covers but I've seen
you not to go too late I love their
bombs I tell you how to do it you gotta
do it and inside you know like it's not
even his ability it's how he uses it
oh yeah we're getting to that continuum
but uh let's get back to the Witcher
before we get off of it is just how
y'all feel about that that's all I mean
I thought it was amazing that dak one
game that we thought no one was
listening to is going to get time so
really funny you finish up real quick
cuz I yeah I was just gonna basically
say like I think the idea was really
awesome it was like too many people love
The Witcher the world is huge my brother
has drove into that world before rental
the book so it's like the content is
definitely there which I don't even know
that much about it but to be able to
learn about it in a Netflix show
honestly I'm intrigued like I didn't
know too much about the whole world but
the idea what he's capable of what he
can do I mean it's definitely gonna be
on Netflix so I mean you can throw
clothes pretty much out the window so I
mean they've got they've got the right
platform for it you just put it in the
right hands I think it can be done well
I would like a lot of what Netflix has
done so and I think it's in good hands I
mean house of cards
lots of the Marvel stuff has been great
and as to varying degrees on some of
their shows but like I think they've
done very well with a lot of their
proprietary content so I'm very excited
to see what they'll do because I I think
they're the big thing that Netflix does
that puts them apart from other people
is they do really good casting for the
most part yeah well this is this is the
thing that kind of I'm not 100% sure oh
they said they started production
already but then they never spoke about
a cast so they haven't necessarily said
that it's live action it could actually
be an animation which they have yeah
there was speculation it could be
underneath a vein of the cat like
Castlevania so I mean you know you guys
might not be an animation but I'll be
okay yeah we found that really I think
which it works perfectly as kind of like
a monster of the week type like like
cereal where every week is a different
monster that he's hunting and then
there's this overarching story to the
role um so yeah I think if they do it as
an animation you can even get deeper
into the lore without having to break
the bank
on the special effects and stuff like
that um but the biggest thing that they
compared it to was the Game of Thrones
yeah so yeah they put that much money
into it that would be some I mean they
have the money to do it so again I think
I just think it's interesting that they
said they're in production they didn't
say pre-production they said production
and it's been no talk of a cast or
anything like that so yeah I was like
I'm literally looking at announcement
rejoice Netflix is making a live-action
which for TV series oh they are that
good okay there it is it is Thank You
missus is that is that direct who is
that directly from the quote this is
Paul Tassie on Forbes doing the report
so you're gonna would say the damn
production I guess they're keeping it
under wraps s because obviously
everybody wants to know who's playing
the role ah yeah again I think it's in
good hands I think they have that format
and it's perfect for because one one
criticism you have of a movie per se if
it would moon which a movie is that you
can't get into the depth of the
character in the two-and-a-half hour
movies it's just impossible so something
like this gives the character the it is
just do and gets to break the a you know
break down all the aspects of the role
and make it maybe even expand more upon
what the game is done
obviously on CD product doesn't have
anything to do with this is more the
author books this is going off the books
right remaining off the books so I will
say Netflix is they're the kind of
people that they will ask them for input
what they said they said could be happy
to but they didn't necessarily say they
would or they've been related to um
gotcha
I don't think CD Projekt has the best
relationship with the author because
he's pissed off that he sold them the
rights really being off the games
because he's so long way to be honest if
it's the Arthur is it he and that's
working with Netflix or Netflix
something I mean let's let's because
I'll they can make a good game but let's
be real here for a narrative TV show
it's best to the person who wrote it
Nathalie absolutely I mean that's the
source material yeah I mean laws are you
gotta jump in yeah yeah I think you took
pretty much every point I was gonna say
yeah I think it's I think it's the
perfect medium I mean III really I'm I
mean let's be honest you know comic book
video game movies that comic video game
is particularly definitely don't doesn't
have the greatest history right and
generally don't translate well to the to
the big screen because you have that one
shot if the production is not good and
to me it's like one thing about this
series is like you you really can get
character development you know I mean
that's one of the things that you know
when you watch i watch those Netflix
series when you watch a daredevil on
these things this is like having that
episodic format it's just so to me
advantageous to it you get to build that
character and get you excited about that
so yeah I'm excited about it you know I
think it's something that has potential
you know once I heard it was going that
route Netflix is on a roll as we all
know all this shows for the most part
I've been knocking about the park you
know and it actually been handled by a
whole bunch of different teams if I
understand it's not like there's just
one specific team that you know doing
all their series kind of things so there
bankrolling I think is I think it's a
good look so I'm curious I think this
could break the streak you know video
games possibly yes hopefully yeah I
think it's good but um I think the same
idea just the fact that as you're saying
Netflix is the right platform for some
of these because
it's hard to tell a video game which is
usually going to take any narrative is
going to take six seven hours and you
can probably delve more into it think
about doing a division series on Netflix
oh my god leglock to get you back on
kings beside now you have what you could
do like I don't know just Netflix is a
very unique platform just the idea of
the binge but the multiple episodes same
way daredevil the first time I watch
that series like you dive deep some
people may not like how far you get into
the characters but that's the nuance of
watching some of those things as you get
them yeah sounds like um I'd be pretty
excited I'd look forward to it I've no
idea we're probably gonna see in about
seven years but one necklace that's
whatever of them I'm kind of excited to
bond tonight ooh just the fact that
these things are going to be living on
Netflix forever as long as Netflix is a
service it brings people that might not
otherwise be attracted to these
properties it gives them the opportunity
to know whatever one day they just hang
out in the house and put on Netflix
anything was just what your thing and
then all of a sudden they're invested in
this this this what we consider be a bit
obviously is from books but what we
consider to be a video game world and it
you start bringing people in that might
not otherwise have any type of um
affiliation to these sorts of properties
on it just a quick story like my my my
sister of recently purchased all bunch
of Merida brother stuff from my from my
four-year-old nephew and my niece and I
and I'm like where did they get all this
love for Super Mario because he doesn't
really play Nintendo my niece kind of
plays you know her 3ds and whatever
they've been watching the Super Mario
Brothers Super Show on Nettie style
they've been watching Captain blue all
bad and this is where all the Super
Mario love comes from now they want
everything Super Mario so again the end
that's because it just lives there on
Netflix so I mean you do that with The
Witcher there's somebody you know three
years down the line watches it and falls
in love with The Witcher that that's
positive thing yep absolutely so yeah
that's what we got on it I think what
King is just some excitement some
we shall see we're gonna try to wrap
this thing up it was a very intentional
shout out to Lord in front I know yet
the internet thing is you struggling we
happy to get him for at least that hour
cause he was having he was in the remote
location whether you get that like that
that fake comcast whatever he was called
it can I be doing with but I felt this
cream eyeshadow an infernal shoutout for
games as a quarters those guys doing
good thing and shout out the TX aw dumb
boys put in work in arm we always gonna
definitely have you back and I was
always a pleasure to get you guys on it
in talks in gaming so we are going to do
our outros and I'm gonna pass it off to
the co-host with the cold most Lord
addicts got a lot of controversial type
who's going on in spotlights tell me
what you guys um so if you don't follow
them on YouTube definitely you know go
over there and do that follow me on
twitter follow paul everyone on twitter
saw in the description tomorrow i'm
going to be having a destiny static
spotlight you know we're going to be
talking more detail pretty much what you
sell here it's just you know i I try to
stay away from the topics that we have
on iron Lords podcast of the next day
I'm having my my attic show on the
PlayStation conference I'm having it
with Jack Lew Johnny from wepa well and
I Nicodemus from a Fame entertainment ik
it is little boys yes and day after that
I'm gonna have a fable at Expo like work
out you know I'm having that with
mamacita from Fame and I'm having it
with a cow from the inner circle so
definitely those check those out they're
all live I just want to have a couple
shoutouts you know as much as anchorman
V gets on my damn nerves to choose
Oliver Oliver thought he was always been
a hundred percent with us you know you
definitely helps us with the podcast you
know I wanted I do want to say ant he's
in that comment section every iron Lords
podcast I seen there all the time
you know we do have our speculations too
and we go at it sometimes especially
over Halo Wars to but we won't go into
that you know I want to take all of you
for being in the in the comments and you
know really getting that conversation
keeping people in this chat you know
being very interactive with the UH with
the chapel
we all appreciate
that you know definitely fall all these
people on Twitter I want to thank you
know I want to personally thank Inferno
for coming on the podcast actually was
he definitely fit really good in with
the flow of the iron Lords podcast
definitely check out txr and check out
his uh his podcast you both solid
podcasts and you know definitely check
out my addictions coming up this week
thank you guys for watching no doubt
Lord
Ibanez yes sir I will find you and
always a pleasure to have the fam as you
are family you won't you you fuzzball
have like a semi permit you see there
the round table this corner like sure
that I put my chair I pull it from the
other side of the room and be like are
they no I think you guys froze getting
the invites I appreciate it just they
always be far at the conversations fun I
tend to sit back a little bit let you
guys hash it out and try and throw my
two cents in whether it's a mic drop or
not whatever like Mel but always you
guys can check me on on Twitter on
twitch been streaming a lot more quite a
bit actually so got my affiliate status
pretty recently so that's just been kind
of cool mommy got a few bits honestly
it's like just those moments where
people like I was doing the Destiny
stream just analyzing it and going over
bits and pieces and by the time I got
done with the stream gave me a nice
little cheer and donation just that's
little stuff blows me away so it's just
like it's always awesome the support and
you guys have been great in that too so
I thank you guys for just any time to
jump on here and just shoot it up with
you it's like great topics every time
and so yeah
twitch Twitter YouTube ebon test every
place eb o and t is and thank you guys
hats off to the iron Lords to inferno
for jumping in and everybody in here
always an awesome group of guys and in
the end we love games and we love having
a good time so we're just going to keep
up that absolutely lovely bro
and of course Lord sovereign non
incognito himself we're gonna find
people find you find people can find me
on xbox live at being sovereign a PSN
bx7 one word and on twitter at a loss of
io p no doubt in law king beloved
preemie move was in rare form today we
can provide
you can talk on Facebook Xbox Live
Twitter and Instagram the real king
david on king david OTW I love the
podcast every week I like to say thank
you for everybody that's in the chat on
one side you know work out the kinks
with my laptop
I'll be back it in the chat with you
guys he's jumping around in there um
Lord inferno
thank you for showing up Evon setts it's
fantastic I couldn't wait for this week
for you specifically because of destiny
too and I know like your superfan
soloing any rate only nightfall my man
you have much respect for me I need a
team Oh and I don't even think about
doing it by myself
um I just like to say thank everyone for
you know showing up for sticking around
and for contributing to subscribers we
are over a hundred and five strong a
shout out to the king get in a very
short time thank you for finish about
that well we appreciate that and I was
being the last especially the last one
shot okay barring that big time and I
look a little gay you guys know you can
find me it's all in description all that
good stuff get a lot out of me but say
something
I was gonna say you know where else you
can find Lord King on his phone on
Amazon top and every big games at you
but uh like I said shut up everybody to
chat like love tremendous and I'll keep
supporting us like I said the these III
prediction series we got one more coming
up we got some surprises for you next
week I'm really excited about that as
well and we're gonna close this thing
out and um I said III is coming soon and
the Lord's got some stuff cooking as
well we're still the best podcast you've
never heard and we continue and
appreciate all the support and on that
note we are out peace